so vitals was the most requested session
here at playtime today so we're gonna
kind of assume that you'll know about
vitals I'm gonna tell you what we're up
to recently also we're going to go into
a bit more detail about what Jan
announced earlier and then Fergus who's
gonna come up who's going to tell you a
little bit more about why you should
really really care about your vitals so
first thing I made a bit of an
assumption that you do all know about
your Android vitals right good night
show of hands maybe everybody who's
using android vitals not bad but i can
see you know quite a few here that
didn't put their hands up so just for
you and your vitals it's 15 engineering
metrics covering five different
performance areas that really give you
insights into the things that users care
about the most so it represents the
performance and quality of your app as
experienced on by real users on real
devices in the real world and most
importantly it gives you as business
leaders maybe people outside of the
engineering team insight into what is
normally just an engineering metric it
gives you a very great brilliant
overview i suppose of what is the what
are the main quality issues that are
really affecting your app and perhaps
why you're not seeing the performance on
your in your your business metrics that
you may expect but having said that it's
still really really important to to
recognize this these are still
engineering quality metrics it's up to
your engineering team to actually fix
the issues that vitals identifies
therefore it's really really crucial
that your engineering time actually is
using vitals and is going into the play
console and is looking through they're
going through all of the metrics that we
have available to to see what issues are
coming up because those are the guys
that can fix it so for all of those here
who who didn't put the end up just now
come join the hundred thousand
developers including it I think about
half maybe more than half of the
developers that I saw just now
that are using vitals already so I just
want to do a quick overview of what's in
vitals today and a few things that we
launched recently and then I'll go into
a bit more detail about what we're
launching today
so Android vitals is split into five
different performance areas so we have
stability battery rendering and then
since Google IO we added apps start at
time and also permissions now within
those five performance areas we have 15
different metrics for you those metrics
are broken down by at least three
different dimensions now the set of
dimension varies from one metric to
another but generally we have things
like operating system version apk
version release tracks or whether it is
alpha beta or prod and then there's a
few other metrics which are kind of more
specific to a particular sorry a few
more dimensions that are more specific
to particular metrics so we have a lot
of data that you can really really delve
into here and we go into a little bit
more detail that the things that we
launched at i/o as well so with app
startup time we're trying to help you
provide quick launching apps so across
the the three different states that an
app may be in we want to allow you to
measure how often an app takes too long
to render its first frame so from cold
start if it took 45 seconds or more than
that'll be highlighted on the first
metric and same for warm start and hot
start and so forth so we you know when
the user is is waiting too long to
actually get into your app in the first
place we also added permissions now you
all know about the dynamic permission
model that we added not so long ago - -
to Android now what we find very often
is this users if they are just presented
with a permission dialog hey I want to
use your camera hey I want to use your
storage and there's no context for the
user there's no kind of nothing to tell
them why they should grant the app this
permission then quite often they'll go
well no you know and your app may not
then have the the full functionality
that you want
user to experience so this will track
how often your users are denying the
permissions that you may rely on in your
app to provide the full experience
so this is where perhaps you would if
you have a poor performance on this
metric then it's an indicator that you
need to add that additional context when
you're requesting permissions so you can
actually provide the value to the user
what is what is in it for them what's
what what's really the reason behind
granting this permission we also added
category benchmarks now this is where
you can compare your android vitals
performance to that of your competition
within the same category so if for
example your crash rate is 2% anything
that's that's kind of okay I'm only
crashing on 2% of your daily sessions
but then you look into the category inch
mark and you see across your category
well actually all of your competitors on
average they're crashing 0.1% 0.2%
something much much lower than you are
then you know that you are well behind
and that you need to catch up with your
competition we also added anomaly
detection now this is really really
really powerful this will send you an
alert when any of your metrics or excuse
me four of your metrics are not
responding crash excessive wakeup and
partial background wakelocks
when they start trending upwards or
perhaps even when they're spiking maybe
you've done a new release or you've
enabled a new feature server-side or
something and all of a sudden your crash
rate goes through the roof this will
send you an alert so that you can take
action on that as soon as you possibly
can
it requires you to go into the console
and sign up for this alerts make sure
your engineering teams in particular go
and do that so that they receive these
alerts and they can take action before
your users start complaining then the
last thing we announced at Google i/o is
core vitals now there's 15 different
metrics in Android vitals today
now we identified some of those that are
particularly important to the user
experience these are the ones you see on
the screen here so they are crash rate
and nr8 which are from the stability
performance area and then partial
background wakelocks and excessive
wake-ups which are from the battery sort
of resource usage per performance area
now the reason we did this is because
these as I said these are the ones are
the most important to the user
experience now there's a lot of metrics
there 15 but these are the ones that we
have prioritized in order to help you
prioritize we've also added an
additional piece of information to each
of these metrics which we call the bad
behavior threshold this is essentially
the line in the sand for the store as a
whole if you're below the bad behavior
threshold then you can consider your app
to be performing well on that metric and
then we have one defined for each of the
the core vitals they if you're above it
then that means you've got you need to
fix that's that metric and you need to
do it pretty quickly now I'd wanted to
go in a little bit more detail as well
about what CN referred to earlier that
we're launching today so this is where
we we're linking android vitals with the
pre launch reports now pre launch
reports if you're not familiar with it
is a system built into the play console
where we take your app and run it on
real devices sitting in a data center on
what we call the firebase cloud test lab
and we automatically navigate through
that app and see what the app does we
record with screenshots we record video
we capture stack traces if it crashes we
capture video of its crashing if it does
we capture the logs and we capture a lot
more metadata than you will typically
find in android vitals because vitals is
pulling its data from real users in the
real world and there's a lot of privacy
implications of what we can pull and
what we can't so if a particular crash
has already been identified by pre
launch reports then that crash will be
linked to in the android vitals UI now
so you'll have
all of that metadata are available to
you so you can really figure out much
more quickly how to action and fix that
crash that it that is occurring
similarly we've updated free launch
reports to make that link in the other
direction also if pre launch reports
they identified a crash that is actually
already happening on production devices
as I said real users real world then you
will see that in the pre launch reports
UI as well so this will allow you to
prioritize the crashes that have been
identified in pre launch reports and
really work on the ones first there are
actually affecting real users so now I
want to hand over to Fergus he's going
to tell you a lot more about why you
should really really pay attention to
your vitals
[Applause]
everyone my name is Fergus Hurley and
I'm the product manager for Android
vitals hands up here who wants more
five-star ratings and last one star
ratings okay hopefully everyone unless
you're working for one your competitors
so we learned a lot of lessons or last
year from developers I who have actually
improved their vitals and I'm here to
share some of those lessons with you
today feel free to keep your phones out
and take photos these lessons so we did
analysis over all the reviews on Google
Play in English and what we found is
that when users are talking about
performance and stability issues they
talk about the forty percent of the time
when they leave a one-star at review and
when people leave a five-star review
they're talking about speed design and
usability over seventy percent of the
time so we all know that performance is
important and we feel it when our apps
and our phones don't actually behave
correctly but here we have the data to
show how important it is to users and if
you want to be able to improve your
rating you need to be able to focus on
these areas yourself I said we've been
learning from developers over the past
year and developers have been using our
tools and as a result we actually seen
improvements in the ecosystem so we've
seen a nice bump in users talking about
speed design usability over the past
year when leaving five-star reviews but
more importantly we've seen a large
reduction of users talking about
stability and bugs and resource usage
which includes battery and memory usage
when leaving one-star reviews now let's
jump into some examples of developers
who have been improving their stability
of their application so the team behind
merged dragons at very popular Zenga
game was able to reduce their number of
one-star reviews by over 50% by being
able to use vitals to pinpoint issues
within their application this enabled
them to be able to boost their user
engagement while saving their
engineering time engineering team a lot
of time in terms of debugging issues
the tap games team was able to reduce
their a and/or rate by over 80% because
they were able to pinpoint a specific
set of devices that are actually having
an N or issue and they were a Knorr are
unique to the play console this is where
your application is not responding and
the Android platform is able to detect
that and this is not reporting and many
other performance reporting tools and I
really encourage you to check out the
A&R section of the play consoles so you
can be able to deliver a more responsive
application to your users read at the
very popular app who is able to reduce
their crash rate like 75 percent using
an revives but more importantly as a
result of the here benchmarks that we
actually have available which where you
can see how you compare with other apps
in your category as Gavin mentioned
earlier they were able to understand
that now they're one of the top
applications out there in terms of being
very stable and this enabled them to be
able to share that data with other
people within their company so the
engineering team was able to say hey it
was worthwhile for us to invest in
improving our stability over the past
few months because now we're one of the
most stable apps out there another
feature that Gavin mentioned earlier was
anomaly detection this is where you can
be able to get alerted when you have a
major change in foreign performance of
your application the team behind global
had signed up for anomaly alerts and
when they had a spike which increased
their a-a-alright by 94% they
immediately got alerted about that using
Android vials and then we're able to
disable an add SDK that was causing that
issue and be able to work with that SDK
to fix the issue and then be able to
release the fixed at the reduced Orion
or way back down to its previous level
and I deliver on maximizing their
monetization again now we don't think
you should give up working out features
and improving the application in other
ways but we do think that you can do
focused effort on performance and here
you can see a quote from the ABA English
team which spent one quarter focusing on
half performance improvements
in a 4.6 star rating for their
application obviously you need to do
more than just have good violence to
have a 4.6 star rating an application
unions a really great application and
you we know for sure though that you
will never get a 4.6 star rating out if
you have terrible violence because so
I've given some great examples of
individual app developers who have
improved their performance we also
looked at the developers who had engaged
most in the play console since Google
i/o amongst our top developers and what
we found is that they reduced their
class rate by 50% over the past few
months and this is really great because
this results in a much better experience
for Android and users we have three
billion plus active installs that are
much more stable as a result of this top
10% of our developers so great that
these other developers are having
success using violence because it's
really impacting me and my business well
we looked as apps that actually have a
high crash rate and as Chan mentioned
earlier users who have a higher crash
rate leave 52 percent more 1 star
ratings than users with a lower crash
rate and 22 percent more 1 star ratings
with a higher a and origin great so that
finishes the stability and bug sightings
now we're gonna move on to the resource
usage side so resource usage is battery
memory network usage and a lot of these
metrics are interrelated so one of the
metrics we have on your battery in the
play console and reviled section is
excessive network use this is bad free
end users in two ways one is you're
consuming their data fine which might be
very expensive for that user and two it
consumes at their battery unnecessarily
the two metrics to pay most attention to
though in this area are the core vitals
that Gavin mentioned the core vials in
battery being excessive wake-ups and
stop way clocks in the background
the Jamo team was able to reduce their
excessive wake-up rate by 70% and just
look at this quote for a second here
so they appreciated the visibility and
diagnostic skills that Android Vilas
provides because very few tools out
there actually help you be able to
understand how your battery is being
used on end users devices and what they
say is they wouldn't have even noticed
our Benedict a fix this issue without
Android vials to really encourage you
and your teams if to be able to a user
Android biosphere to understand how are
you impacting users batteries great so
now we've covered how you can avoid
those have one star ratings and as I
said we've increased the number of users
talking about these five star
performance areas over the past year but
we want it now over the next year see an
even larger increase and users talking
about these things and so let's jump
into some of the metrics that we have to
be able to help with that there
MercadoLibre team which is behind one of
the most popular e-commerce destinations
in Latin America if not the most popular
I was able to use Android files to be
able to understand how are their
permission requests being appreciated by
users and what they saw is that when
they built this new feature into their
application they required this at
permission to be enabled that their
permission denial rate was much higher
than other apps in their category and so
they worked on redesigning their
application and changing their strategy
for how they requested that permission
and as a result they were able to
increase add the users who were able to
get access to that feature and reduced
their permission denial rate
now the mikado Libre team is a pretty
large team it's if hundreds of engineers
working on their and on their
application they have many teams working
on different parts and as a result one
team introduced an issue into the
application that caused a regression in
the startup time but by keeping an eye
on their Android file if they were to
understand that this happened and then
work with that team to actually be able
to add to bug that issue and reduce back
their startup time to what it was
previously
start a time is really important and
Android violence measures the stereotype
from when the app is first interactive
now there's a lot of other parts of your
application that you might consider and
that users might consider to be part of
the startup as well and so the local
team used Android boils and firebase
performance monitoring to be able to
understand how the performance was
throughout the whole lifecycle and what
they found is that it they were actual
performance was terrible
so they actually rewrote their whole
sign up and login process and reduce
that I started trying this reflected in
buyouts and in firebase performance
monitoring and I think it's important to
point out here why would you use fires
performance monitoring and Android
violence well we're design droid BIOS
get us data is the core question to that
so Android vitals is based on the data
that comes from the Android platform
itself and this is powered by the
hundreds millions of users who have
opted into sharing their data with
Google and you our partners the firebase
performance monitoring tool is based on
you instrumenting your own application
and you then being able to collect data
a certain point in your application and
it fundamentally comes down to timers
and counters in the firebase forints
monitoring tool and so if you want to be
able to really track these performance
pieces that are important to getting a
5-star rating I really encourage you to
use firebase forints monitoring are
another performance monitoring tool in
your application itself to go to track
individual events ad that you really
care about great we've covered some case
studies from many different stakeholders
here today and on the top right here you
can see some of the core people that you
would expect to have been using
performance data at historically except
for it was very difficult for these
people to be able to get the formance
data in the past so we have an Android
engineer head of mobile engineering and
a product manager one of the things that
I'm most proud of with Android boils is
how it's changed the conversation around
a performance in companies and now we
have many stakeholders outside of the
core engineering team working on the
application
using performance metrics are as
government to these engineering metrics
so we had quotes in this in the
presentation from lead mobile product
manager CTO a VP of product and a CEO Oh
even and so as we all know quality
across the whole Android system is
improving and if you and your whole
entire company are not looking at your
performance of your application and
these technical metrics then you're
gonna be left behind
okay go one last I study that we did
this just shows how increased quality
equals increased engagement what we did
is we looked at games that had users
with a really high crash rate and users
who had a low crash rate it costs the
same game and what we found is that
users had two men and a half minutes
less engagement in the app when they had
a high crash rate and the trend was even
stronger for users who had a high a
and/or rage now this equates to if a
user was playing your game every single
day to about 20 hours a year of less
engagement time in your game and we all
know time is money so really focusing on
increasing your quality will increase
the engagement in your product great so
we're actually gonna open it up for
questions right now and so I think
there's mics around if anybody wants to
ask a question and Gavin you wanna come
back up wait that's it
if you put your hand up they'll bring
them like to you yeah okay we also do
any any questions no okay great so we're
gonna be around throughout the day I'm
you can catch us turn the brakes
I will also be in the Blue Room at 12:30
and you can come chat to us there
there's resources at this link here
where you can be able to learn more
about vitals and BSA and improve your
application I we also I would like to
thank everyone that we were able to
share case studies from today and we
hope this you work on improving your
application so that we can be able to
share at case studies of your success in
our talking next year thank you very
much everyone thank you John
[Applause]